my name is Yan heg I'm the lead singer of
The Swedish metal band amanar and I'm a huge
hockey fan I've always loved the intensity of
the game the speed but most of all I love The
Passion of The Players theame they're so
scared NHL players call that chirping I'm
in your kitchen both your kitchen I'll trip at
you all day but I'm going to teach him how to
sing all right Parker Kelly welcome to Sweden
yeah thank you for having me yeah did you have
a chance to look around Stockholm at all yeah
it's been pretty cool my first time in Europe
so I'm really really loving it all right well
I see that the players on the eyes they do
something called chirping yeah but I thought I
was going to teach you how to really sing all
right really like like a get out there yeah they
get it out there and we call it growling so it's
it goes something like this Parker [Music] Kelly
yeah that's so good so good before you do any of
this though you kind of have to warm up a little
bit okay push with your stomach relax the face
[Music]
and there we go you see feel it's getting like
deeper yeah perfect yeah so that's basically
what you need to do so who's your Nemesis on the
ice like who's who's who's the worst player to
probably like like Noah Greger if I could get
under his schem and just like shoot a growl
at him like he'd be like who yeah exactly so
now when you're playing the global scus and
you're sitting in the locker room warming up you
[Music] like yesterday mean and then you know and
then when you feel like you want to scream
you go into the shower room or whatever you
go
hey
grer there we go there it is when you're on
the eyes I want to see a real growl out of
you and really give it to your opponents I'm
sure when like the game's going like oh you
got the adrenaline yeah the adrenaline's going
so my growl is going to be like off the charts
and I'll be thinking of you so thank you
very much for teaching me and thank you it
was a pleasure pleasure meeting you and learning
from you and yeah AES she would do one together
to the camera yeah one last growl one last growl
yeah let's get it from Deep In the Belly are you
[Music]
ready